ta télé alors je porte je suis désolé
c'est ma mère me l'usure n'est pas cinq
minutes j'ai allumé et sur la télé il a
écrit un texte 1 alors que moi je veux
voir tf1 et m'en fais ton qui commence
comment on fait tu appuies sur menu et
après tu choisiras la source elle y
arrivera pas
tadic menu
menu ces maisons maman menu ces maisons
pourquoi tu me dis menu ces maisons bon
tu sais quoi je te battrais ta série ce
soir sur le replay bon soit elle ne peut
pas savoir ce que c'est
merci à cause de toi j'ai raté mon
feuilleton je t'ai dit que j'allais te
le mettre en replay pourquoi est ce
qu'elle a dit à ripley
le replay mme amina c'est celui
streaming
sur
comprend rien à ce que racontent ce
qu'ils ont
[Musique]
ils vont n'importe quoi avec les
horaires
champagne tranquille tous l'aider
maman tu disais que tu viendrais dormir
à la maison un de ces jours et pour la
récurrence c'est aujourd'hui
bon aller 2 2 mais comment ça de dos
je dis ça je ne suis pas là je suis une
petite abeille
carole carole oui maman
ça
comme ça avec ton mari si vous voulez
avoir un beau problème j'ai mes boules
quiès merci maman je pense que le
message est bien passé
serveur que maman est la moins de 20 cm
on entend tout ici
ces boules quiès ah oui pardon j'ai à m
[Musique]
oui ce sera parfait pour la soirée
échangiste tu veux parler de la soirée
troc la soirée où on échange les objets
on y songe quand même avec plaisir
des donc rentré tard à les soirées
échangistes ça traîne toujours en
couleur
et soirée histoire ils sont juste parce
que bon le bridge scrabble à cahors
blues un moment où
vous fais ça depuis quand mais ça fait
des années
je sais déjà que mon mari lui il aimait
pas y trouver qui avait trop de dieu bon
effectivement ce serait mieux c'est plus
de jeunes ça vous dirait de venir non
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah je vais me coucher cette soirée m'a
cassé les pattes
[Musique]
le faire